si el viaje a casa toma 39 minutos a qué
hora chris tiene que salir de tal forma
que esté en casa a las seis y cuarto
entonces dibujemos una línea de tiempo y
pensemos qué va a pasar aquí esto es por
lo menos como yo lo visualizo o la forma
en como yo puedo resolver este problema
y voy a poner las horas antes de las
seis y después de las seis así que
empezaríamos en cinco y luego nos
iríamos hasta las siete solo para estar
seguros de abarcar todo el tiempo y
poder dibujar la línea un poco mejor así
que déjame dibujarla lo más recta
posible y por aquí tenemos a las cinco
las seis y por acá tenemos las siete en
punto ellos nos dicen que tienen que
estar en casa un cuarto después de las
seis y que quiere decir un cuarto
después de las seis
bueno pues un cuarto después de dicha
hora está entre las seis y siete y por
aquí podríamos decir que está la mitad
entre las seis y siete
aquí estaría un cuarto después de las
seis y si queremos especificar que es un
cuarto después de las 614 entre las seis
y siete sabemos que entre las seis y
siete hay sesenta minutos que es una
hora por lo que esta distancia es un
cuarto de sesenta minutos que son quince
minutos por lo que esto de aquí son las
seis y quince la hora en la que chris
debe estar en casa
y ellos nos dicen que toma 39 minutos
para llegar a su casa por lo que va a
tener que salir 39 minutos antes de tal
forma que llegue justo a esa hora a las
6 15 entonces vamos a poner los 39
minutos antes de esto el tiempo que
tendrá que salir antes para llegar a las
6 15 por lo que cuáles son los 39
minutos antes de las 6 15 y ahora la
forma en como mi cerebro está procesando
a esto es que me gustaría pensar bueno
cuánto tiempo le tomará para poder
llegar justo a esa hora entonces por
aquí teníamos las 6 15 y 15 minutos
antes de estos son las seis en punto
entonces por aquí pasaron quince minutos
y estaremos abarcando dicho tiempo
entonces cuánto nos restaría para poder
decir que le tomo los 39 minutos antes
de las 6 15 si ya llevábamos 15 minutos
de recorrido
entonces restamos 39 menos 15 por lo que
serían 24 minutos antes de dicha hora
antes de la
entonces cuántos son 24 minutos antes de
las seis en punto y una vez más nos
vamos a figurar esto y vamos a mirar que
a partir de las 6 15 se regreso 15
minutos para llegar a las 6 en punto y
luego tenemos que ir 24 minutos antes de
las 6 en punto pero 24 minutos antes de
las 6 en punto van a ser cuántos minutos
después de las cinco en punto y una vez
más sabemos que 60 minutos hay en una
hora por lo que 60 minutos menos 24 van
a ser 60 minutos menos 24 igual a 36 y
lo puedes hacer inclusive en tu cabeza o
lo puedes hacer en este orden decir
bueno
0 - 4 es como 10 menos 4 son 6
acarreamos 1 entonces 5 menos 2 son 3 y
son 36 minutos después de las 5 entonces
si hablamos de 24 minutos antes de las 6
en punto es equivalente a decir que son
36 minutos después de las 5 en punto
entonces esta hora de aquí
son las 536 o bien en mi cerebro está re
estas serían buenos 60 minutos de una
hora menos 20 son 40 pero falta restar
otros 4 minutos entonces 60 menos 20
menos 4 nos dan los 36 minutos después
de las 5 así que cuando kris debe salir
de casa son las 5 36